One of the great overlooked pop songs of
2016 was drake's feel,
no ways of his April release views,
I think overlooked because in terms of
radio play,
I think the song was lost in the shadow
of one dance and controller to dancehall
and few singles that dominated the grip.
Sonia from way back when you know that I
don't play,
which is a shame because I feel no ways
I think is just as good,
if not better than those songs and more
than that,
it tells an interesting story about
Drake's place at the center of Popular
Music in 2016.
Now I want to spend most of my time
discussing the production here,
but lyrically we should note that feel
no ways treads over some familiar
territory.
He's lamenting the end of a relationship
that he's had to cut short because it
was holding him back.
Personally.
This is drake and full emotional pop.
Now some people come to drake for rap.
Others come to him for RNB inflicted pop
like this,
but most of us love him and his music
for the bridge that he navigates.
Between those two things.
A bridge that was really first explored
in a big way by Kanye west on his hugely
influential album,
eight weeks in Hartland gene may cause
within this 80 style electro r and b
that young drake found a lane for
himself to dominate and perfect.
A drake himself cited Kanye as an
inspiration and drake's longtime
producer and collaborator,
no afford 40 should be described as one
of the early Eureka moment.
The experience of hearing drake rap over
Kanye say you will the first track from
eight.
Wait,
why do I feel so alone?
Like everybody passes out the role.
I tried seven years later,
drake and 40 have shifted the pop focus
into their own center of gravity.
This Toronto Cold Edis Electro R and B
rap pop hybrid that you hear everywhere,
most notably in the musician straight
has signed his own record label.
October is very unsound or ops,
the producer from one of those
extraordinary omen from Majid Jordan and
rnb duo composed feel no ways and it's
sort of the perfect distillation of the
sounds and moods that we've been talking
about.
Don't feel no ways is made up.
Essentially have three parts,
Greg's voice,
a break beat drum patterns and an
electric piano that plays a simple but
catchy chord progression that goes like
this,
c major seven,
g major seven and a minor seven with a
few little flourishes here and there.
This progression pretty much loops for
the entire song,
but what's more significant than the
courts are the sounds that omen selected
for the song.
The synth being used here is the famous
Yamaha dx seven,
which was only made between the years of
1983 and 1989.
The dx seven is one of the most
commercially successful synthesizers of
all time.
It came equipped with 30 odd factory
meant to emulate different instruments.
Now,
in theory,
you could program more sounds in
addition to this,
but the interface was so notoriously
confusing that most people stuck to the
presets and as a result,
a whole decade of music became infused
and associated with these instantly
recognizable.
Sounds to the point of cliche
considering how tacky the dxf and
sounded by the end of the eighties,
it's amazing how draken omen
reappropriate it for this driving upbeat
pop song.
In 2016,
of course it wasn't sound as fresh by
itself and that's why I think the true
cleverness here is how omen pairs this
reality.
DX seven,
emulation of a fender Rhodes piano with
another classic Edis Element,
a drum sample from the very origins of
hip hop.
This breakbeat comes from an absolutely
incredible album called scratch him,
which is an early hip hop record from
1983 put together by maybe the most
unlikely guy.
Imagine that's Malcolm Mclaren,
a British impresario who helped launch
the punk movement in the UK by founding
the sex pistols in 1975 in the eighties.
He went solo and released an album
called duck rock under his own name,
which brought together African music and
American hip hop,
helping to popularize the sound and
America and exported around the world on
duck rock and dlx scratching.
Mclaren collaborated with Djs from one
of the earliest and best hip hop radio
shows.
The world's famous supreme team,
which aired at 4:00
AM on the east coast for an hour.
Omen brilliantly pulled the beat from
their song,
world's famous and put the DJ's own
voices and the breakdown
because way
two main elements pulls from both sides
of drake's musical aesthetic,
eighties R and B and hip hop and fuses
them under his voice which pops out of
the instrumentation like cold water.
I tried to sleep in the song is the
perfect encapsulation of the pop music
that drake and his team have defined in
the last few years.
A kind of music that feeds its
influences within the elements that make
it up.
Of course eventually pop music,
we'll move on.
The style will change.
Someone new will move to the center,
but it's good to appreciate the moment
we're in while we're in it,
especially in those rare times when the
most popular
artist is also one of the best.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I'm so the nerdwriter crossed 900,000
subscribers,
which um,
you know,
when I started this five years ago,
it never occurred to me that there would
be such an audience for the show.
And the more audience that comes on,
the more people that watch,
the more responsibility I feel to just
keep making better and better and better
content.
So thank you for watching.
If you want to subscribe to this channel
and help me get to a million,
you can click that box that I've set up
over there.
Um,
I want to thank Chris Salamone who made
these awesome rewriter coasters from
scratch,
just one of the amazing things that fans
of the show do,
but he's got a great channel called four
eyes woodworking,
which I'll link to below.
Definitely check that out.
I wish I could wear to work.
Thank you everybody so much for
watching,
for being a part of this show and this
community.
Um,
and I'll see you guys all next
Wednesday.